number of segments created.
If you want to keep a main store,
you have to keep a segment.
If you want to keep an institute,
you have to have two branches.
You have one here and one there.
So you have to have two branches
in the same panel.
Then you have the masters
in the inventory.
In the masters, in the transactions,
whether it is a report,
you will get the inventory separately
in which you will work.
Right.
The first step is
to have masters created in the system.
Like in your institute,
the data of all the items
should be in this.
So in the inventory, you will have items
like your table, chair, pen, pencil, chalk
etc.
So in the first level,
you have to create your items
You have to view the existing items.
You have to edit the created items.
So this is the option.
In the same way,
you have units like items.
For example,
your chemical will be in liters.
It will be in liters.
Erasers will be in your pieces.
Like furniture,
it will be in your numbers.
In which unit will you save it?
So that is the unit.
Now I will tell you how to create an item.
You will click on create.
In this way, your interface will open.
This item code is non-mandatory.
For example,
you have erasers.
You have two types of erasers.
You have to define them by code.
Or you can keep them even.
Whatever code you have,
you can do it according to your code.
It means that it is non-mandatory.
So I have created erasers.
Which item will be in your group?
Is it stationary data?
Is it an instrument?
In case you feel that you are putting an item group
which does not exist in the item group.
So you have an icon here.
You can create your item group here.
For example,
I need stationary data.
So I can create my item group here.
I have to keep it in the primary.
It will be individual.
It means that you are creating
a group under an existing item group.
For example,
you have three or four types of erasers.
Or you can take pens.
For example,
you can take ball pens,
gel pens,
and you can keep them under pens.
And you can keep pens under stationary data.
In that case, it can be used.
Like stationary data.
You can create categories.
Yes.
For example,
if I create it here.
Hello.
Sorry.
I was a bit busy.
I was lost in the internet.
Ok, sir.
As you put the item here,
it will share the item successuler.
Ok.
Whatever item you have created here is yours.
You have to hit cross edit
for an existing item.
You have to book and click edit.
You can search all from here.
You will start searching all by clicking edit.
Go down the name. You already exist.
Then
segments
primary
then
normal
this has
success.
created
same option.
first level
single time.
down.
pencil.
the icon.
She can.
masters.
Okay.
Yes.
items.
for example.
right.
the system.
the opening.
opening.
every year.
the CR.
Then stock transfer.
For example,
As I told you, we have purchase entries.
Sorry, you purchased the erasers,
whatever items you purchased.
You have purchased them and kept them in a single store.
Now you have to transfer them to different departments.
Like the department you are in, the teaching department.
Like our 1st, 2nd, 3rd, 4th, 5th, 6th, 7th, 8th etc.
So all those that you are taking.
They will be in stock transfer.
For example, your main store.
For example, the central store.
From the central store,
you are transferring it to which store.
For example, I am transferring it to this store.
Which item am I transferring?
See, I did it from here.
Which date is coming?
Stock transfer is coming.
Which item am I transferring?
I will enter the item from here.
How much quantity is going?
Narration.
Why am I doing it?
I will put a reason for it and save it.
You can also upload additional documents.
This is how stock transfer works.
Apart from that, how will you enter the purchase?
Your purchase is here.
From whom you have purchased, in what cash.
All that is your purchase entry.
This is not just the purchase bill.
It details everything.
How much purchase has been done.
Even the document is uploaded.
This is the corresponding reporting section.
What is the stock?
What is the closing stock?
What is the item?
This is the end number of reports you have.
The way the items are coming,
you will have the end number of reports.
It will be used according to you.
What is the transfer?
How much is in it?
This is the time.
This is the end of the stock reports.
Any queries, sir?
Okay, sir?
Yes, ma'am.
Okay.